now to northern california and a
devastating development in the fight to
control the state's largest wildfire
this year officials say two people were
found dead in a car after the mckinney
fire tore through a neighborhood near
the oregon border the fire has now
burned through an area larger than the
city of seattle and many more people are
unaccounted for jonathan bigliotti is in
siskiyou county in northern california
jonathan good morning
and good morning to you this fire was
driven by high wind and during the worst
of the fire storm flames jumped from
home to home many people actually chose
not to evacuate ahead of time
and were forced to flee as the fire
barreled down
the race to get people to safety and to
locate the missing is underway in the
fire zone there's so much loss
of the families here teams are searching
through destroyed property to locate
residents who may have died in the
flames the fire exploded so quickly in
this neighborhood it engulfed entire
homes everything that you see here just
destroyed the bodies of two people who
officials say waited too long to
evacuate were discovered in this vehicle
after it was engulfed by the fast-moving
inferno when they did try to escape
their driveway gate apparently wouldn't
open it shows how swiftly these fires
move courtney kreider is a spokesperson
for the siskiyou county sheriff's office
she says nearly two dozen people are
still missing and that number could
increase what we're trying to do today
is get a better reference of people that
are either unaccounted for
or unfortunately fatalities
with thunderstorms moving into the
region the damp conditions are helping
firefighters but the massive fire still
burns out of control the lightning
strikes could be disastrous the one
thing we've learned about thunderstorms
is that we can't predict what's going to
happen
of the thousands of evacuees many are
staying at nearby evacuation centers
including 81-year-old harleen schwander
who lost nearly everything but her life
my house is gone all my furniture all my
clothes shoes coats boots
everything's gone
and we counted dozens of homes that look
just like this you can imagine the
difficult task search and rescue teams
now face as they search for the missing
rain overnight helped stop this fire
from progressing but there is still more
wind and possible chances of lightning
in the forecast
jonathan thank you